und der stolz der hat jetzt eine riesige
krise an der backe er muss sie mit lösen
das ist eine ganz wichtige eine ganz
ernste woche in dieser woche wird über
krieg und frieden in europa entschieden
russische bodentruppen die im manöver
üben für eine invasion in die ukraine
hubschrauber dort stationiert tausende
panzer und eben rund um die ukraine
herum überall bodentruppen wir wollen
ihnen das einmal hier auf der karte
zeigen wie umzingelt mittlerweile die
ukraine ist von russischen truppen
schauen sie einmal auf hier auf den
schirm überall hier hat die russische
armee mittlerweile truppen hingestellt
rund um die ukraine sowieso besetzt das
vergisst man ja oft krim also dort
sowieso schon unrechtmäßig russische
soldaten die dieses gebiet eingenommen
haben ebenso hier in der ost ukraine und
dann rundherum in belarus und auf dem
russischen staatsgebiet überall tausende
soldaten hubschrauber fallschirmjäger
panzer in dieser situation also befindet
sich aktuell die ukraine der
bundespräsident frank walter steinmeier
hat gestern gesagt das ist eine schlinge
die um den hals der ukraine liegt und er
hat sich direkt an wladimir putin
gewandt und hat gesagt lösen sie herr
putin diese schlinge um den hals der
ukraine und jetzt haben wir sie zu hause
unsere zuschauer einmal gefragt für wie
wahrscheinlich halten sie dass das
tatsächlich vladimir putin einmarschiert
in das staatsgebiet der ukraine und das
sind die zahlen
sie haben geantwortet
43,7 prozent von ihnen sagen ja wir
rechnen damit dass putin tatsächlich
einmarschieren wird in die ukraine nur
38 prozent sagen nein und weiß nicht so
die lage noch überhaupt nicht so richtig
überblicken können sagen
18,3 prozent das also ihre antworten wie
es in dieser woche weitergehen wird und
noch versucht europa versucht ja auch
die bundesregierung alles mit
diplomatischen mitteln kanzler olaf
scholz ist gerade auf dem weg in die
ukraine morgen dann nach moskau aber wie
die russische regierung darauf reagiert
das zeigt ein zitat des russischen
botschafters in schweden viktor tatar in
zerf er sagt entschuldigen sie die
klaren worte aber wir scheißen auf ihre
sanktionen das sind sätze aus der
russischen regierung an diesem tag
russische regierung der russische
botschafter in schweden sagt wir
scheißen auf ihre sanktionen und in
diesem moment haben wir hier bei bild
live mit einem der größten gegner putins
mit garri kasparow gesprochen dem schach
weltmeister er hat uns ein exklusives
interview gegeben
putin die stirn bieten das macht er
garri kasparow
schachweltmeister politischer gegner
putins mehrfach wurde er dafür auf der
strasse verhaftet aktuell lebt er im
exil in den usa im großen bild interview
warnte er jetzt vor einem angriff putins
auf die ukraine
leider läuft hier anders als beim schach
denn beim schach gibt es regeln an die
sich beide seiten halten müssen aber
putin kümmern regeln nicht er verletzt
sie unter kommt in der regel einfach
damit durch
putin ein mann der sich um keine regeln
schert ein mann bei dem man immer mit
dem schlimmsten rechnen muss sagt
kasparow
bevor wir über strategie sprechen müssen
wir erkennen wir haben hier ein echtes
problem denn wenn die leute jetzt sagen
wir wissen doch gar nicht ob putin
überhaupt die ukraine angreifen will
dann sage ich ich weiß es auch nicht
aber ich weiß er hat so viele länder
angegriffen er hat so viele
internationale verträge gebrochen er hat
seine politischen gegner töten lassen er
zieht eine blutspur hinter sich her egal
wo er hingeht der einzige weg diesen
gangster zu stoppen ist sicherzustellen
dass für ihn die kosten eines angriffs
auf die ukraine höher sind als der
nutzen die post
doch genau diese klare botschaft fehlt
bisher sagt putin kenner kasparow sie
fehlt von deutschland es tut mir leid
aber deutschland ist eine der größten
hoffnungen putins um die westliche welt
zu spalten was für ein satz eine
abrechnung mit deutschland mit der
bundesregierung auf ihr also läge putins
hoffnung
alles was bisher macht ist halb airport
sowie die entscheidung deutschland keine
waffen an die ukraine zu liefern das ist
doch das nächste zeichen dafür dass
deutschland halt weiter business as
usual machen will mit den russen und
solange herr schröder in deutschland
weiterhin angesehen wird als
respektabler politiker und nicht als ein
mann gegen den mann wegen korruption
ermitteln muss wird putin deutschland
nicht ernst nehmen
und auch von der moskau reise von
kanzler scholz morgen hält kasparow
wenig die könne er sich sparen sagte er
im bild interview
ich setze da sehr geringe hoffnungen in
den besuch von herrn scholz in moskau
statt eurem kanzler nach moskau solltet
ihr waffen in die ukraine schicken
das sind klare worte von garri kasparow
putins feind sozusagen einem der größten
putin gegner in der welt er sagt alles
was die bundesregierung alles was olaf
scholz bisher in diese krise macht ist
nur halbherzig erscheint jetzt direkt in
die ukraine bild vize paul ronzheimer
ist gestern abend direkt dorthin gereist
direkt nach dem richtigen fragen in die
ukraine gefrorenen geflogen und paul du
kennst das landgut was spürst du derzeit
wenn du den menschen dort in die augen
schaust
patricia wenn ich hier durch kiew laufe
ich bin gerade in diesem moment an einer
stelle wo an die toten ukrainischen
soldaten erinnert wird denn das ist das
was wir klinische menschen immer wieder
sagen deutschland schaut doch her es
gibt schon so viele tote menschen und
wenn ich dort in die gesichter schaue
ich war selbst viel an der front dann
sind da ganz ganz viele junge soldaten
die seit 2014 hier ums leben gekommen
sind aber natürlich noch nie war es der
fall dass die ukrainische hauptstadt
dermaßen im zentrum steht dass die
menschen tatsächlich angst haben dass
hier kiew angegriffen werden könnte der
ukrainische botschafter hat gestern zu
mir gesagt es könnte sein dass es
großflächige bombardements gibt und wenn
das so sein sollte dann wird sich die
zahl derer die hier in der ukraine
sterben maximal erhöhen ist sind mehr
als 10.000 menschen bereits ums leben
gekommen aber wenn es passieren sollte
dass russland hier ein feld hier nach
kiew einfällt dann sprechen wir über
zehntausende vielleicht hunderttausende
tote pauli menschen dort in tierfoto
gerade bist wie leben ein leben wie wir
da gibt es eigentlich keinen unterschied
die gehen morgens ganz normal zur arbeit
die kaufen ganz normal ein deal ebenso
mit ihren familien wie wir das kennen
hier in deutschland wie stellen die sich
jetzt auf so dramatische warnung ein auf
einen krieg auf ein bombardement
das ist ein bisschen das verrückte muss
man sagen als ich gestern mit dem
flieger von berlin richtung kiew
geflogen bin da war der fall das war ein
komplett überfüllter flug und ich saß
neben jungen frauen die hatten ein
partywochenende in berlin die haben ihre
fotos gezeigt die sie gemacht haben dort
in berlin und dann habe ich sie gefragt
habt ihr keine angst wenn ihr jetzt
zurückkommt hier nach kiew und sie haben
mir gesagt nein wir haben keine angst
wir kennen den krieg schon lange was
sollen wir tun wir sind in dieser
situation wir sind allein gelassen aber
was bringt es wenn wir jetzt in panik
verfallen also tatsächlich versucht man
hier in der bevölkerung noch irgendwie
die kontrolle die ruhe zu bewahren auch
der ukrainische präsident sagte immer
wieder dass es am ende ja man diese
panik nichts führen dürfe wir sehen
hinter mir hier dass es eine übung von
soldaten die eben erinnern an ihre
kameraden die bereits gestorben sind
paul ronzheimer ist für uns in kiew in
dieser woche der wohl eine entscheidung
fallen wird über krieg oder frieden
danke dir paul